bravo j'ouvre le second débat de ce sens
public volontairement décalé de
l'actualité du jour débat de société
consacré à la crise de l'agriculture bio
l'inflation de longue durée change nos
habitudes de consommation les ventes
baissent notamment dans les grandes
surfaces les agriculteurs souffrent pour
écouler leur production comme ce
céréalier de lesson rencontré par Fabien
REER la récolte du soja basson plein
dans la ferme de Thomas lafoiss chez ce
céréalier bio pas de pesticide
une machine se charge de séparer les
graines des mauvaises herbes le soja
représente seulement 20 % de l'activité
de Toma la locomotive de son
exploitation c'est le blé alors ce blé a
été récolté le 20 juillet entre le 15 et
le et le 20 juillet on est sur du blé
meunier de très belle qualité c'est un
blé qui a beaucoup de protéines un beau
poids spécifique un blé de qualité qui
ne trouve pas preneur vendu normalement
autour de 500 € la tonne son prix est
descendu à 250 € la tonne Thomas la fois
travaille à perte aujourd'hui on est sur
une situation de crise qu'on a jamais
connu où produire du blé nous coûte de
l'argent on surveille le la température
du TAS pour essayer de la faire
descendre le plus bas possible en
température plus c'est bas plus
longtemps on le conservera et au vu du
contexte actuel on s'attend à devoir
conserver très longtemps le le PL sous
le hangar pour amortir le choc
l'agriculteur céréalier mise sur le
maréchage en vente directe mais cela ne
suffira pas à combler ses pertes sur le
blé 50000 € par an pour Thomas il y a
sûrement plusieurs facteurs
d'explication à à cette crise la
première qui est annoncée par tous les
opérateurs qui achète qui transfore ou
qui vendent c'est une baisse de la
consommation à quelques kilomètres de là
ce magasin bio vend les fruits et
légumes de Toma lafouiss la vitrine de
magasin bio c'est le fruits et légumes
les consommateurs viennent pour le
fruits et légumes pour du local
Christian ha possède deux magasins dans
le département de lesson il constate lui
aussi un désamour du consommateur en
particulier depuis le covid la
consommation du vrac a énormément baissé
pendant la période du covid
automatiquement il ne fallait pas
toucher les silo et cetera donc les gens
avaient peur ils étaient avec leurs
masque donc la consommation de vrac a
baissé de 30 %. toutes les personnes qui
venaient de façon sporadique avant le
covid ou pendant le covid ne viennent
plus certainement à cause de l'inflation
une grosse baisse du chiffre d'affaires
pour mon magasin et puis pour tous les
autres magasins bio de France il y a
quand même 252 magasins bio qui ont
fermé l'année dernière frappé par des
faillites en cascade les acteurs du bio
dénoncent la concurrence de la belle
moins exigeant pour l'environnement tel
que le haute valeur environnementale ou
HVE il rappelle surtout que
l'agriculture bio est un mode de
production vertueux qu'il faut soutenir
sans pollution de l'eau ni de l'air elle
engendre des coûts supplémentaires mais
permet des économies mis en direct pour
la
société l'agriculture bio en chute libre
on en débat tout de suite avec Dominique
charger bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
président de la coopération agricole lur
verdau bonsoir bienvenue directrice de
l'Agence Bio Frédéric d bonsoir et
bienvenue vous êtes journaliste auteur
de ce livre le bio au risque de se
perdre publié aux éditions bchet Chastel
et Mathieu croissand est rester
évidemment à mes côtés un un premier
chiffre pour ouvrir notre débat 60000
fermes engagées en bio en France en 2022
ça représente un peu plus de 14 % des
des fermes françaises surface totale 2,8
millions d'hectares ce qui fait de la
France pour la 2è année consécutive la
première surface bio en Europe ça c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle Dominique
charger vous représentez plus de 2000
coopératives 2100 coopérative et 800 ont
fait le choix du bio est-ce que la
tendance est en train de s'inverser
est-ce qu'il y a des agriculteurs qui
font le marche arrière en quelque sorte
alors on a fait une enquête justement
pour faire un peu un point à date auprès
de nos 800 coopératives qui sont
aujourd'hui engagés en bio donc elle
constate pour la moitié d'entre elles
une situation qui s'est singulièrement
dégradée elle reste quand même confiante
pour 90 % d'entre elles en revanche si
on va plus loin vers le producteur donc
l'adhérant de la coopérative pour 62 %
il reste quand même confiant et tourné
mais ça veut quand même dire qu'on a 38
% des agriculteurs qui aujourd'hui se
posent la question et on a vu
effectivement dans certaines filières
des producteurs qui ont fait le choix de
se déconvertir comme on dit c'est pas un
terme qu'on aime c'est pas une situation
qu'on affectionne mais en revanche il
faut se mettre à la place des
producteurs parce que je pense que c'est
quand même là qui est le drame
aujourd'hui c'est que nous avons
aujourd'hui des producteurs dont les les
les les les bâtiments de production dont
sont vides parce que il n'y a plus de
marché et je pense que la filière bio
est probablement le martyre de ce qu'on
observe aujourd'hui en terme de nouveaux
comportements ou comportement adaptation
des comportements de consommation par
rapport à la crise du pouvoir d'achat
c'est dire que on a observé à la fois
une baisse en volume globaux hein sur
l'ensemble des consommations puis ou en
même temps ce qu'on appelle une descente
en gamme c'est-à-dire ben les les les
consommateurs vont vers une gamme
inférieure et donc le bio n'a aucune
solution pour pouvoir se rattraper et
aujourd'hui on a une filière qui souffre
vraiment oui alors on va évidemment
rentrer dans le détail et peut-être
essayer d'esquisser des solutions mais
d'abord je reste sur le constat avec
vous lor verdau l'Agence Bio groupement
d'intérêt public créé par les ministères
de l'Agriculture et de l'écologie vous
faites des études sur le bio de la
pédagogie auprès des citoyens et puis
vous financez aussi les les PME du
secteur via le fond avenir bio on on a
titré le bio en chute libre est-ce que
vous êtes aussi pessimiste ou aussi euh
si on senit en fait euh du point de vue
d'un agriculteur bio il y a pas qu'un
seul débouché qui sont les deux circuits
que vous avez évoqué dans le reportage
il y a six débouchés c'estàdire qu'il y
a quatre circuits de vente pour le bio
qu'on consomme à la maison la
consommation de biodomestique il y a la
restauration collective donc les
cantines puis a la restauration
commerciale et actuellement si on se
pose d'un point de vue du potentiel on
est qu'à 6 % de nos courses nous
alimentaires les Français en bio HM
c'est pas du tout assez ça nous met au
niveau des États-Unis on est on n pas
bon en consommation Quiou ça et ça ça
s'arrange pas si on parle de la
consommation si maintenant on nuance le
constat que vous faites chute libre dans
l'ensemble des circuits il y en a
effectivement trois qui sont en baisse
donc la grande distribution qui a
déféren des référenés des produit bio il
y a les magasin bio qui ont été en
baisse donc les 3000 magasins qui ne
vendent que du bio et effectivement
comme il y a eu 200 fermetures on est
passé 3002 à 3000 magasins ça c'est
ressenti parce que derrière c'est des
filières et les artisans en revanche la
la vente directe la vente à la ferme qui
est très très forte en bio puisquil y a
plus de 26000 fermes bio sur les 60000
qui V en direct ça représente 42 % à peu
près c'est énorme c'est dans l'ADN des
bio V direct là ça s'est bien maintenu
et c'est à 4 % donc il y a encore des
facteurs de de stabilité et la
restauration on en parlera un peu plus
tard je quand même je je vais je vais
citer la Fédération nationale de
l'agriculture biologique qui est quand
même très alarmiste communiqué d' d' y a
quelques semaine le gouvernement et tous
les acteurs actifs dans le développement
de l'agriculture biologique doivent
réagir en urgence pour ne pas ass
assister les bras coisés à l'enterrement
de la transition agroécologique de la
France Frédéric dans à quel point il y a
urgence et peut-être aussi quelle est la
part de responsabilité de la filière bio
elle-même oui il y en a il y en a une
alors la la bio est pas plus le le
martyre comme vous disiez d'un
changement de comportement et pas plus
le martyre que enfin c'est facile de euh
je rends votre question plutôt parce que
j'ai l'esprit d'escalier dans ma tête et
là je vois les rouages qui sont en train
de s'enclencher pour répondre à votre
question abité de la filière bah la
filière elle a elle a joué d'arrogant
c'est-à-dire que voilà il y a un
maniquéisme très français qui consiste à
dire l'agriculture conventionnel c'est
pas bon du tout c'est sale c'est des
pesticides c'est du cancer et face à ça
il y a que le bio chevalier blanc le
camp du Bien ah le bio c'est bien ça va
sauver la planète ça va sauver les gens
ça va sauver les
agriculteurs mais ce modèle manikéen ben
B il tient pas parce que parce que la
crise de confiance a aussi touché les
gens qui se rendent compte que du bio
qui des tomat bio qui ont été cuilis
dans le sud de l'Espagne par des
immigrants syriens battus par des
mafieux c'est pas tout à fait du BI en
fait c'est pas du tout un label de droit
du travail le bio c'est un label
agronomique et on
importe et le bio le monde du bio a
laissé les gens projeter ce qu'ils
voulaient sur le bio justement parce
qu'on a créé un modèle dual un modèle
maniquéen or or les gens ce qu'ils
veulent et ça a été très clair durant
les débats pour le projet de loi Galim
ce que veulent les gens et on le voit
aujourd'hui c'est des produits qui est
rassure des produits qui les rassurent
par une incarnation c'est des produits
locaux n donc le local prend le pas sur
le bio oui parce que le local rassure
même à tort ou à raison parce que
derrière le local avec le local on met
effectivement la figure de quelqu'un
c'est la figure du boucher c'est la
figure du paysan c'est la figure de
quelqu'un qui incarne quelque chose dans
cette boîte noire qui le CIRC ça vous
fait réagir d'abordg ensuite le ver ENF
moi je pense que c'est une situation
effectivement inédite parce que
jusqu'ici le bio avait toujours été en
prog progression et on vit je dire une
crise euh profonde qui est liée sans
doute à cette question de pouvoir
d'achat quand même d'une manière
générale et en premier j'allais dire
premier première cause de cette crise
enfin moi je pense quand même est-ce
qu'il y a quand même des consommateurs
un peu perdus hein onit par des labels
quand plus effectivement mais si on a
fait une erreur c'est celle sans doute
de ne pas forcément considérer
l'adéquation des volumes de production
avec le développement de la consommation
en tout cas dans certaines productions à
certain moment j'ai vécu certaines
crises dans le lait assez profonde qui
étaient quand même lié à cet effet là
donc moi je pense que ce qui doit
d'abord qu'on doit d'abord retenir comme
leçon c'est de structurer des filières
structurer des filières c'estd avoir au
maximum une adéquation entre l'offre de
production et la demande la deuxième
c'est sans doute d'avoir été un peu
dogmatique politiquement en tout cas sur
dire qu'il fallait développer le bio moi
je pense qu'on doit avoir des objectifs
de transition
agroécologique et dans lesquels on est
engagé en revanche le bio n'est
peut-être pas la même la seule solution
le bio répond à des aspirations sûrement
un
imaginaire qui n'est peut-être plus
celui qu'on avait il y a quelques années
mais on a on voit ça dans d'autres
segments de qualité où finalement les
mentions sur lesquelles on s'est engagé
ne répondent plus au consommateurs
d'aujourd'hui et il faut
seosition est-ce que vous n'avez pas
oublié de réfléchir sur les prix surtout
puisque vous étiez dans un marché en
forte croissance où tout se vendaient
euh a priori je je pourquoi c'est si
cher le bio est-ce que vous avez pas
enfin vous ça vous conna est-ce que la
filière bio a pas trop Margé pendant des
années et
C justement au moment où on se parle si
je prends l'exemple du lait biologique
ou il est à peu près au même prix que
celui du lait conventionnel puisque le
prix du lait conventionnel a beaucoup
augmenté donc c'est c'est on raisonne
plutôt en écart de prix que nous n'avons
plus aujourd'hui donc il y a un gros éc
deou on est d'accord mais le BIOS se
développé à ce momentl et là finalement
on a plutôt un prix qui se resserre
effectivement tout a monté pas trop
tirer sur la corde il a toujours un
écart de prix allez je vis que la parole
se se ventile le plus équilibrément
possible que équilibr c'est pas merci
beaucoup il un peu de fatigue à un
moment de la soirée équitablement
possible merci Mathieu l verd il y a il
y a plusieurs critiques qui ont été
exprimé notamment par Frédéri
l'arrogance et puis Mathieu soulevait la
question du prix qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à ça moi j'ai peut-être pas
connu la même période que ces messieurs
mais ce que je sais c'est que la nation
française s dotée d'un objectif de 18 %
de bio on veut du bio dans les champs on
a besoin de sortir des pesticides on
vient de voter un plan écophyo donc il y
a pas trop de contestation si on veut
avoir 18 % de bio dans les champs il
faut qu'on ait 18 % de BI dans
l'assiette donc il faut plutôt que de
dire oh là là le bio se casse la gueule
et cetera il vaut mieux dire on veut
accueillir les agriculteurs qui veulent
faire le choix du bio parce que ce que
dit pas votre reportage c'est
qu'actuellement on va se retrouver avec
une France sans agriculteur si demain on
on compte que sur les fils et les fils
agriculteur pour assurer les départs en
retraite on a une France sans
agriculteur c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est Françis pur enfin si le marché est
en train de s'effondrer ça March sacré
est-ce que vous avez déjà vu des
consommateurs se rouler par terre en
demandant des voitures électriques non
on les a fortement encouragé on a
structuré des filières des marchés et
des infrastructures en fait le le la
transition elle elle ne peut pas être
que le fait d'initiative individuelle le
consommateur dans l'état actuel il peut
même pas faire le choix du bio parce
qu'on lui explique pas ce qu'est le bio
pourquoi c'est bien gérer gérer le
consommateur le
sait tout fait pour vous accueillir il y
a 20 anst on fait des études tous les
ans un baromètre de la consommation on
demande à 4000 français alors vous en es
o dans votre rapport au bio on se rend
compte que les Français savent plus ce
qu'il y a derrière ils nous disent oui
c'est un label dout 5 % parce qu'il dout
ils ignorent en fait les problèm c'est
que l'ignorance bon ben écoutez allez-y
allez-y sur les baromètres on est assz
on est assez confiant puis que c'est
vraiment des questions qu'on suit chaque
année et ensuite pour ce qui est de de
de de d'aller parler de enfin je sais
pas des imports ça je comprends pas
pourquoi à chaque fois on nous parle des
importations en bio comme si c'était une
spécificité actuellement le bio qu'on
consomme il est mine France à 72 %. et
si on retire les produits exotiques qui
poussent pas sous nos contré on mange 80
% de que cré ses imports c'est le doute
de ces images où l'on voit que l'on
commence à voir d'agriculteur bio
d'arboriculteur qui pulvéris
il y a des diplômes d'État il a le
diplôme d'État de la transition du c'est
fait sur le bien c'est fait sur le bon
c'est fait sur la planète fa sur la
santé on pilote la communication
collective que l'on fait avec l'ensemble
des interpro donc des gens qui sont pas
que bio et je peux vous dire que on a un
ensemble de messages communs qui sont
son en ce moment dans les sur les ondes
sur pour nous pour la planète pour nos
producteurs locaux biorflex consomo bio
ça met tout le monde d'accord je sais
pas de quel dogmatisme il y a sans doute
des on m' parlé souvent des talibios
j'en ai pu en croiser quelques-uns mais
bon ça reste une
minoritébi ça reste une minorité
globalement actuellement on a sur les
l'ensemble des Français on en a 10 % qui
détestent le bio qui en veulent pas bon
ben pourquoi pas il y en a 15 % qui en
CH jour entre la parole je je je
reprends la main parce que on n pas tout
à fait répondu à la question sur le le
le prix que que que posait Mathieu et
elle est évidemment important je vais
vous donner la parole à l'un et à
l'autre c'est promis mais je voudrais
donner d'abord un chifffre ensuite un
témage un chiffre qui concerne la grande
distribution parce que finalement quand
on parle de de crise du bio de chute
libre c'est effectivement principalement
dans la grande distribution qu'on le
voit - 13 % des ventes de bio entre
janvier et juillet et là-dessus voilà le
chiffre je vous propose d'écouter le
ministre de l'Agriculture Marc fen qui
parle de la marge de la grande
distribution sur le bio
écoutons pourquoi sur les les produits
bio la marge produite par la grande
distribution est plus grande que sur les
produits conventionnels c'est une bonne
question parce qu'près tout si on veut
soutenir on devrait faire la même marge
parce queune tomate bio une tomate
conventionnelle pourquoi la marge est
plus importante sur le bio parce que on
s'est mis dans la tête que c'était un
produit qui était adressé qu'à des gens
qui avaient les moyens et donc c'est pas
ça qu'il faut faire ce qu'il faut dire
c'est à la fois l'intérêt qu'il y a à
développer le bio en France il y a
d'autres modèles mais le bio est un
modèle intéressant et le deuxième sujet
c'est d'essayer de stimuler l'Allemande
en essayant d'expliquer ce que c'est
Dominique chargé sur le prix sur les
prix moi j'avais constaté quand même il
y a quelques années de la décision d'un
ministre un des prédécesseurs de Marc
fen justement qui avait décidé que euh
les tomates bio produites sous ser euh
avant le mois de avril ou mai vous allez
me me corriger pour le le le la date
exacte ne pouvait pas être commercialisé
en bio en France alors qu'on pouvait les
importer de Belgique ou d'Espagne ça ça
explique en partie pourquoi on a des
prix qui sont supérieurs c'est pas le
seul il y a de toute façon mécaniquement
un prix qui est supérieur pour avoir en
cûpt de production en agriculture
biologique qu'en agriculture
conventionnelle donc vous avez toujours
un positionnement prix qui de toute
façon sera supérieur eu ensuite est-ce
qu' effectivement la grande distribution
marge plus sur le bio que sur les
produits moi j'ai pas la visibilité moi
j'ai pas la visibilité aujourd'hui sur
les marges qui sont appliqués par la
distribution sur chacune des catégories
de produit je constate en revanche qu'il
y a de gros écarts dans la distribution
entre certains produits et d'autres moi
je j'ai dans les entreprises que je
connais euh des marches qui peuvent
aller de 10 % puisqu'ils peuvent pas
aller en dessous aujourd'hui avec le
seuil de revente à perte jusqu'à 35 40 %
donc il y a effectivement des écarts
importants de marge dans la distribution
suivant la valeur des produits suivant
la façon dont ils sont consommés fréri
dan enfin çaétait souvent étudié he CCV
Que Choisir euh et je sais plus quelle
autrre association de consommateurs qui
ont fait des études qui on font tous les
ans et qui montrent que la grande
distribution marche deux fois plus sur
les fruits et légumes bio que sur les
fruits et légumes conventionnels sous
prétexte que étant bio étant moins
protégé ils vont pourir plus vite mais
c'est tout le problème de la grande
distribution la ferme France comme il
faut dire aujourd'hui n'a comme acheteur
que quatre centrales d'achat et jamais
aucun ministre surtout pas Marc fenau
euh ne vont revenir là enfin c'est une
situation qui est unique le monde
agricole dépend de quatre centrales
d'achat qui font exactement ce qu'elles
veulent on va pas faire une émission sur
la grande distribution mais le souci il
est là et le souci comment dirais-je il
est d'autant plus important pour le bio
que corrigez-moi si je me trompe mais au
début du bio le bio était sorti de sa
gangue militante aussi par la grande
distribution qui avait voulu viser les
les parents de jeunes enfants donc ils
ont accueilli plus de bio dans leur
rayon je fais court en en laissant
attendez en laissant aux agriculteurs le
soin de former leur prix s et
aujourd'hui ça se retourne sans prendre
la défense de la grande distribution
parce que ça va pas être mon r c'est pas
trop c'est pas trop mon attention en
revanche on n pas que quatre clients on
a quatre clients dans la grande dans la
grande distribution qui représente 60 50
à 60 % de la consommation on a aussi la
restauration collective la restauration
commerciale comme ça a été dit et dans
la restauration collective il y a la
restauration publique du tout la part du
B dans la restauration il y a la
restauration collective il y a la
restauration publique qui ne qui n'a pas
pris ses responsabilités dans les lois
égalim qui ont été voté donc en
2018 il y avait euh
comme intention comme action le fait que
la restauration publique devait avoir 50
% de produits sous signne de qualité
dans son approvisionnement dont 20 %
c'est pas 20 % c'est 20 % de bio oui ça
ça n'est pas appliqué aujourd'hui on en
est très loin on en est encore très loin
mais pour pour pour plusieurs raisons la
première c'est qu'on avait d'abord du
mal à approvisionner mais il ils ne
remplissent pas cette condition mais
pour une raison très simple que je veis
quand même ajouter c'est qu'il faut
quand même le financer et que les
collectivités territoriales en
particulier doivent prendre sur des
budets
de collectivité qui ne sont pas toujours
là et qu'il faudrait augmenter les
impôts pour estce qu'il y a pas aussi un
choix politique on a positionné ce
marché à destination des Français les
plus riches à la fois les moyens et le
temps énormément de de alors l' le
prouve entre une famille qui mange très
bio et une famille qui mange quasiment
pas bio à pouvoir d'achat égal il y a 12
points d'écart entre leur budgets
respectif pourquoi parce qu'à pouvoir
d'achat égal l'éducation est clé donc en
fait quand vous consommez plus de Bio
vous consommez pas forcément pareil vous
allez pas acheter au même endroit donc
vous n'avez pas le même mix donc ça ce
n'est pas vrai c'est le on on le le le
critère du prix d'ailleurs il y a pas un
prix du bio il y a des prix du bio et je
vous disais que le circuit court est en
forte é en croissance c'est notamment là
où les prix sont les plus compétitifs
mon Président il vous vend des des
pommes de terre digne un triple étoilet
au Michelin 1,30 € le kilo c'est
imbattable et comme par hasard les
Français entre bio local et pas cher ils
ont fait le choix ils ont combinent les
trois ils achète le bio en en achat
direct pour revenir aux cantines on est
à 7 % sur les 20 % de la loi donc ça
c'est les cantines scolaires en
général collec donc donc c'est quoi
c'est uniquement les écoles collège lycé
public
h donc ça effectivement à une perte de
business d'un milliard 5 pour nos
agriculteurs bio français ce qui est
vraiment dommageable donc c'est pour ça
que la loi il faut absolument qu'elle
soit appliquée et actuellement moi je
peux vous citer des dizaines d'exemples
de cantines qui ont 50 60 70 % de bio
pour un cout matière équivalent ou
moindre de leur ptit ne font pas
bah parce que ça demande plusieurs
choses ça demande déjà un de financer un
vrai travail notamment ce que font les
Pat les plans alimentaires territoriaux
ça veut dire que quand vous avez par
exemple comme dans le douisi 150000
bouches à nourrir bah ça veut dire vous
faites un diagnostic et puis ensuite
vous voyez ce dont vous avez besoin par
rapport à vos filières locales et puis
vous payez des gens pour mettre en
relation l'abattoir l'éleveur la cantine
ça veut dire que vous formez vos équipes
dans les dans les cantines ceux qui
mettent plus de bio ça veut dire qu'ils
cuisinent plus ils achètent pas des
fonds de veau chez des industriels ça
veut dire que ils gèent leur gaspillage
il y a un énorme effort qui est fait sur
le gaspillage il passe de 70 g à 11 g ça
ça devrait faire faire des économies ça
mais c'est pour ça que c'est pas plus
cher de mettre du ça veut dire que vous
pouvez pas juste faire contrôle C
contrôle V de votre liste de courses
vous devez remettre à plat votre
fonctionnement et former vos équipes
alors je reviens à Fr je repose un peu
la même question sur le positionnement
du marché du bio vous nous dites non
c'est pas plus cher mais mais est-ce que
il faut du temps aussi pour cuisiner bio
voyez ce que je veux dire il il y a
quand même un certain nombre de critères
moi j'essaie de comprendre pourquoi du
temps pour cuisiner le local aussi he
ouais je peut-être mais pour pourquoi le
marché se se fractionne autant est-ce
qu'il y a eu une erreur de de de
stratégie de positionnement non au
départ non mais je pense que le bio il a
atteint le maximum de ce qu'il peut
atteindre c'est-à-dire un public non pas
forcément argenté mais un public qui a
la capacité à réfléchir sur son
alimentation à réfléchir sur son hygiène
de vie engagé engagé en quel s engagé
qui a qui un regard sur lui-même on
mange ce que l'on est on est ce que l'on
mange et et manger bio c'est pas anodin
c'est pas du tout anodin c'est un
message qu'on envoie à la société c'est
un message qu'on envoie soi-même donc à
mon avis c'est 20 % de la population et
donc vous lu dites que ça que ça va pas
croître beaucoup plus non puis d'autant
plus que à mon avis non d'autant plus
qu'agronomiquement on peut pas faire du
bio au même rendement que le
conventionnel partout que de toute façon
ce sera toujours plus cher l'exemple que
vous donnez je le connais bien Douet
c'est pas loin d'être chez moi Douet
c'est un exemple unique c'est comme où
en sartout effectivement il y a eu un
politique qui derrière il y a a y a 20
ou 30 ans a a a identifié é précurseurs
des Pat il a identifié les producteurs
mais qui étaient déjà sur place il a
identifié les consommateurs il a
travaillé sur les consommateurs tout ça
dans le cadre d'un plan d'urbanisme
général où on confiait au sol plutôt
qu'à la voirie le soin de récupérer
l'eau de puiss qui derrière allait
alimenter allait alimenter l'agriculture
enfin c'est c'est un travail qu'on peut
pas de prot volontarisme
politique sur le territoire actu
programmes alimentaires Territoria qui
sont une façon
deire qui sont une façon de faire
rapidement allez il nous reste un
dernier thème je vous redonne la parole
juste après parce que là on est
finalement sur le le volontarisme
politique qui peut nous amener à la
question des aides est-ce qu'il faut des
augmenter les aides publiques au bio
aujourd'hui en France écoutez sur ce
thème le sénateur Union centriste des
Hautes Alpes Jean-Michel Arnau c'est au
mois de mars dernier le plan national
stratégique dans le casadre de la PAC
supprime l'aide aux agriculteurs bio
l'Agence Bio est sous-financée et les
dispositifs de soutien sont très
insuffisants depuis quelques décennies
les pouvoirs publics promettaient un
soutien massif aux pratiques vertueuses
une souveraineté alimentaire accru et de
meilleur débouché pour nos agriculteurs
quelle est la situation réelle
aujourd'hui les modes de production
sobres en énergie et respectueux de la
biodiversité sont peu reconnus le
contexte économique ne conforte en aucun
cas les conditions de travail de ceux
qui nous nourrissent Haos insupportable
des coûts de production freinage des
exportations signature de de traité de
libre échange comme Mercosur souvent
synonyme de concurrence déloyale le
marché bio est en situation de
surproduction avec une demande toujours
plus moruse au regard de l'inflation
actuelle lor verdo est-ce que la
solution passe par des des subventions
des aides publiques pour faire passer
cette crise qui est peut-être temporaire
du du bio oui le but c'est qu'on
maintienne notre patrimoine de 60000
fermes qui est notre trésor national ça
fait partie des biens communs en
revanche quand il on le la personne
parle de de surproduction on a eu des
des situations où il y avait trop de
lait en France c'est pas un problème on
a modelé une consommation qui fait qu'
on est on mange et on boit beaucoup de
lait en France parce que on a éduqué les
Français on a écouté tous les soirs des
les messages les produits laitiers des
sensations pures ou les les produit vie
bon ben voilà bon ben il faudrait un
même réflexe pavlevien sur les produits
bio sont vos amis pour la vie parce que
c'est grâce à ça c'est grâce à des
moyens considérables à des HE de grand é
pour faire ça pas encore on espère cette
fois-ci ça sera cette année ça sera la
première année d'une campagne d'ampleur
pour justement modeler la consommation
bio parce que on est à 6% de bio les
Danois ils sont à 13 % de bio si demain
on était comme les Danois ou les suédois
ou les Autrichiens on aurait plus de
problème de filière bio donc je trouve
beaucoup pe bien peu d'estime pour nos
citoyens on peut on est champion de la
production européenne de bio on peut
devenir champion de la consommation
européenne de bio ça nous apportera quoi
d'être champion de la consommation de
enfin si c'est pour avoir des champs bio
comme au Danemark qui sont exactement
conformme au champ
conventionnel labouré en permanence où
il y a pas de biodiversité il y a pas un
arbre mais montrezles moi j'en ai jamais
vu depuis des g de il y en a même en
France dans le craésil qui près chez moi
desamp Dom charg votre avis sur les
subventions non je pense
qu'effectivement il faut continuer de
soutenir l'agriculture biologique parce
que le le le le
développement ne peut se faire que avec
de l'accompagnement public en revanche
il faut que ce soit adapté à ce qu'on
ait une adéquation entre l'offre de
production et la demande c'est que je
pense qu'on a aussi
euh sans doute un peu commis l'erreur
d'avoir un développement et et d'avoir
supporté des conversions d'agriculteurs
conventionnels en agriculture biologique
sans avoir forcément maîtrisé le
développement des marchés derrière qui
n'étaiit pas toujours au rendez-vous
jusqu'ici ça s'est bien passé on a géré
des crises mais c'est aussi la première
fois depuis 40 ans qu'on a une crise de
pouvoir d'achat aussi forte c'est avec
une avec l'inflation qu'on a connu donc
ça on est aussi devant quelque chose
d'inédit moi je pense qu'il faut d'abord
travailler à un rééquilibrage de l'offre
par rapport à la demande ensuite je
pense qu'il faut travailler à la
structuration des filières effectivement
il y a un plan qui a été annoncé par le
ministre qu'on ne peut que saluer et
soutenir qui va aussi aller sur de la
communication je pense qu'il faut
redonner vous l'avez dit et je suis
assez d'accord il faut redonner des les
les les vraies mentions valorisantes du
bio pour que le consommateur se les
approprie quelque part parce que je
pense qu'il les a un peu perdu ou qu'il
est un peu perdu dans le foisonnement
des produits différenciants sur lesquels
il est sollicité aujourd'hui c'est le
local effectivement c'est le sans
pesticide c'est le sans ceci sans cela
effectivement est un peu perdu si le bio
évoie quelque chose ça doit pouvoir être
mieux aprè mieux communiqué en revanche
moi je suis assez d'accord ça ne
représentera qu'une part relative alors
de je ne sais pas combien mais 20 % me
semble quelque chose d'extrêmement déjà
important merci à tous fr votre livre le
bio risque de se perdre publié aux
éditions bchet Chastel merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce à ce débat je
vous dis à demain et votre prochain
rendez-vous politique sur notre antenne
dans la matinale manuel bonpard le
député LFI des bouches du rô face à
Orian mansini belle soirée